dans le contexte actuel pas facile
d'avoir 20 ans nous vous proposons des
portraits de jeunes qui nous racontent
comment ils vivent cette époque ils nous
parlent de leurs craintes de leurs
espoirs aussi rencontre ce midi avec
donovan
il a 22 ans et il fait des études pour
être designer web
bamba guèye et sophie et marc
c'est dieu c'est dur
c'est dur d'avoir un temps en 2001 c'est
tout
[Musique]
on m'appelle donovan j'ai 22 ans
j'habite à aiserey un petit come in et
15 min de dijon et je voudrais devenir
designer web
c'est pour faire de la communication ces
contrats aidés dans tout ce qui est
flyers site web
on travaille des éditeurs de sites a la
base je voulais faire développeur web
mais c'était c'est un peu plus compliqué
du coup designers web cham et chéquiers
dans mes projets j'ai travaillé en
intérim je suis qu'un petit boulot comme
préparateur de commandes et des
vendanges j'ai même fait un peu de
maçonnerie
j'ai travaillé dur parce que j'avais pas
encore des buts pas encore ma formation
en vue
j'aime sortir vos jeux vidéo
passer du temps avec ma famille mais je
suis très famille commence à chose de
plus importante
j'aime bien qu'il y ait eu dans ma
famille cuisine de coûts elle aimerait
bien prendre c'est l'actrice mercian
avec mes parents les coups quand on
cuisine j'aime bien les regarder qu'ils
ont pas que j'aime beaucoup moins laissé
le feu c'est un pelage et manière d une
sorte de soupe à l'ennemi soupe de boeuf
mes amis et c'est compliqué ben déjà
j'évite de les voir pour éviter de
contaminer mes parents j'ai vidé sortir
du coup la salle d'affaires de 3 à
l'origine faisait pas vu
et on se parle souvent par téléphone le
premier confinement j'ai plutôt bien
vécu ce que c'était on dire une
expérience nouvelle lui que chapiteau
d'un véhicule d un coût final je n'ai
pas vu passer ce qu'il était en
formation sortait quand même pour il ya
des départs ressenti chez une copine
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'était difficile parce
qu'on est très restreint la cause icône
mais mon équilibre
[Musique]
ce serait totalement l'impression d'être
en prison n'est pas libre moi je veux
rejoindre munger j arthur ça fait deux
mois qu'on les a connus
[Musique]
connue là pourraient pas sensé vue on
sait bien effective à des paris c'est
grâce à son cousin et après ça s'est
fait comme ça il y en a consacré dans
son coin il est fidèle en amitié il faut
toujours compter il est vraiment prêt en
tout cas pour aider dans un temps
nouveau envie j'espère déjà vous ou bien
voyager du coup je sais pas si je serai
en france ou ailleurs
ouais en france utilisons petite famille
des enfants beaucoup d'enfants les
vacances